hey you guys time once again for
flickers of fear my movie review series
so let's talk about this
bonkers movie okay
now i have to say i can't remember
exactly
when or where i first heard about this
movie a cure for wellness i absolutely
did not see it back in 2016
back when it came out in theaters
and for whatever reason it actually kind
of like flew under my radar for several
years after that
but then it seemed like over the past
year 18 months something like that
i kept seeing like a lot of horror
channels i watch and a lot of like
horror blogs i read and stuff like that
it kept
showing up on there like being discussed
or you know hey this is a movie that
didn't get the attention it deserved
like at the time it came out like it
seemed like there was sort of like i
don't know there was just like a lot of
um people talking about it so
i saw that it was on to be and i was
like well that actually sounds kind of
interesting from you know the sentence
or two that i read about it so i was
like i'm gonna check that out
now you'd think that i would have heard
about it because the movie was directed
by gore verbinski who
most people like that are not really
into horror movies probably know mostly
from the first three uh pirates of the
caribbean movies he's done a bunch of
other ones too but those are like his
best known um but i'm honestly mostly
familiar with him because of his work on
the excellent excellent 2002 american
version of the ring which is actually
one of my favorite horror movies of the
2000s
so a cure for wellness
has kind of like all of the really
unsettling but like beautiful but also
grotesque kind of like imagery that that
you know that his
past you know history would imply
uh and though it was a box office bomb
and received really really mixed reviews
at the time
i think largely because of its excessive
length it's two hours and 26 minutes
which is very long for uh for a horror
film but i didn't really uh mind it all
that much and uh i think that the other
main criticism was like some audiences
and some critics like thought the plot
was too ridiculous or
nonsensical or something like that or
you know they had like kind of you know
or it was too convoluted or something
like that but all of those things aside
i actually enjoyed this uh quite a bit
and i think that if you go into it like
if you approach it as i did as sort of
like a modern-day
gothic
horror movie a gothic story that kind of
has this really like creepy mystery uh
has some real kind of grotesque like i
said like very squirm inducing body
horror in it and the third act just goes
balls to the wall like ape [ __ ] it's
great um as gothic literature kind of
tended to do
now it's not adapted from a book per se
but the screenplay which was written by
uh justin heath or hathie i'm not sure
how you pronounce his last name sorry
about that was actually partly inspired
by the 1924 german novel the magic
mountain by thomas mann which is also
about like kind of a swift spa just like
this is
now pretty much
every review of a cure for wellness that
i've read
uh and that i've watched
points out the film's similarity to
martin scorsese's movie shutter island
that is a fair comparison this does like
some different [ __ ] but it's kind of in
the same ballpark
uh there's also shades of crimson peak
uh the guillermo del toro film and uh
the shining you know the stanley kubrick
movie uh but i mean i'm not even gonna
be mad at that because any movie that's
like mentioned in the same breath as
those three i'm just kind of like ooh my
ears just perk right up i'm just like
yeah that sounds like [ __ ] i wanna see
you know what i mean uh this also kind
of has little sprinklings of maybe
frankenstein phantom of the opera
some hammer horror kind of like
stuff to it and a little bit of david
cronenberg because like i said it does
have some like weird body horror medical
type or that type of stuff uh you know
just added for extra spice in there
so i'm gonna say
even though this was you know a failure
a financial failure big time uh you do
have to give props to gordo verbinski in
this i mean it's pretty [ __ ] ballsy
to make a big budget i mean 40 million
that's like a big budget for uh for a
long horror movie like this a big budget
hollywood movie that's this long and
this [ __ ] odd it's just like a really
really weird like movie to come out of
like a mainstream studio
um and it's kind of like a shame that
the fact that it was such a failure at
the box office meant that we would get
fewer of these kind of movies uh you
know going forward uh you know one
that's not based on an already existing
ip or a book or anything like that it's
just you know it's part of a franchise
or a sequel or reboot or anything like
that this is an actual like original
story that somebody actually like just
made up for the movie and you know and
they spent all this money on it and it
looks like really good but you know it's
a little weird and like i said people
couldn't really like relate to it i
guess
i mean i'm not like trying to oversell
it too much it's not a masterpiece or
anything like that but it's still like a
pretty damn good movie and i'm always
going to applaud
the audacity of a filmmaker who's
essentially handed 40 million bucks by
like a main
big mainstream studio and have him say
you know you know what i'm going to make
with this 40 billion dollars i'm gonna
make a completely batshit sci-fi horror
movie with mad scientists dental torture
nutty incest based plot twists and so
so many eels you know what i mean it
takes a lot of balls to do something
like that so [ __ ] bad props there so
what is this movie about alright so we
start out with this little bit of a
prologue i guess you would call it
and you're they're showing us this
unnamed man you don't find out who he is
until later on uh he's working by
himself like so he's all alone in this
big
massive darkened office uh so obviously
he's been working late
uh some kind of financial you know he's
monitoring the stocks on all these uh
computers and stuff
now he's kind of like glancing over
looking at his mail and he sees this
very strange like hand-addressed
envelope with this sort of like black
uh one of those wax seals you know like
on the back i love those by the way you
can still buy like uh
kits to do that and i kind of want to
but i don't really have anybody to write
letters to anymore which is a shame so
he sees this envelope in his pile of
mail um and he goes to open it cause
he's like huh what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
but before he can get it open uh he
actually like clutches his chest really
and he ends up like um healing over and
dying like ostensibly of a heart attack
so we're then introduced to our main
protagonist uh this young kind of
soulless executive uh whose name is
lockhart i don't think that his first
name is ever mentioned uh which i'm sure
was probably a deliberate choice uh if
it was forgive me but i don't remember
anybody ever saying his first name it
might have been written someplace but
everybody just called him lockhart or mr
lockhart so uh lockhart is played by
dane dehaan
so lockhart has just gotten this big
promotion at this uh massive like new
york city financial firm where he works
like he even gets the big corner office
with like the window looking out over
the city and blah blah blah
but he's having like a sort of
celebratory like having some champagne
there with his co-workers uh then he
gets called up to the board room in a
way that kind of sounds like hey come to
the principal's office kind of tone you
know what i mean so he's just like oh
[ __ ] i just got a promotion what the
[ __ ] did i do
so it turns out that the rest of the
board members uh while they admire his
let's call it creative way with numbers
they point out to him that uh this big
account which landed him this promotion
they're like we saw that you did some
like shenanigans there with that one
client's accounts and you probably
thought that you were being real slick
um but the shenanigans aren't as well
hidden as you probably thought they
worked it's like this is amateur hour
so uh basically they're like there we
have this big merger coming up and the
sec is gonna go over our [ __ ] like with
a fine tooth comb and they're gonna find
this [ __ ] uh so they essentially like
kind of blackmail him into doing
this sort of troublesome uh errand that
has come up
so turns out
that the ceo of the company roland
pembroke they need his signature for
this big merger that's going through
problem is roland went off to
switzerland to the spa like suffer some
r r
and he sent them a letter
uh the same kind of letter with the
black uh wax seal on it and everything
like that where he's like uh yeah i've
decided this corporate life it's not for
me it's killing me and it's like maybe
you guys will see the truth one day too
and essentially saying i'm not coming
back
so because they need his signature
they're like well you have to go to
switzerland and bring him back to new
york so we can do this merger thing
otherwise this whole company is gonna
fall apart you're gonna go to prison you
know it's gonna be like a big [ __ ]
ordeal so lockhart uh he's pretty pissed
off at having to like play gopher he
thought he was just gonna like hang out
in his new corner office and everything
was gonna be hunky-dory
but he doesn't think this errand is
gonna take all that long so he's just
grudgingly like jets off to switzerland
now even though this is supposed to be
switzerland it was actually shot in
germany so there was actually like a
pretty you know in the in the wide shots
i think that is actually like a pretty
well-known castle in germany that's like
on top of the uh hill where they shot it
so he's driven up to his destination
this spa like through this town full of
very surly locals they're always kind of
like you know looking at them all
suspiciously like from the windows like
one game like throws eggs at the car and
[ __ ] like that
and uh you know lockhart's like what the
[ __ ] is up with that and the driver says
oh well there's kind of a dark history
between the town residents and the
wealthy folk that stay up there at the
spa he also informs lockhart he's like
wow you're a lot younger than the people
i usually drive up there and um usually
nobody comes back from there like
usually they go up there and they stay
uh and lockhart cia like yeah that's not
gonna happen i'm just going to bring a
dude back and you know hopefully this
will take no more than 20 minutes so
lockhart gets up to the spa which is
like this
just breathtaking uh gothic estate at
the foot of the swiss alps and he
marches in and demands to see pembroke
uh he's like yeah i'm here on business i
don't have time to [ __ ] around uh i need
to take him back to new york it's a
business matter visiting hours are over
though and the spa staff well they're
not overtly hostile to him but they're
apparently very like sticklers for the
rules it's like 20 minutes past visiting
hours they're like we're sorry we can't
do anything about it
so he pulls a karen on
on the woman at the front desk and they
allow him to go see the director of the
spa whose name is dr vollmer he's played
by jason isaacs and he's great in this
now uh dr vollmer seems pleasant enough
uh he tells lockhart that most of the
patients at the spa are these kind of
like high-powered executive types or
like billionaires stuff like that he
says well none of these people are very
well
and they came here to get away from the
rat race that was like destroying them
physically and mentally and most of them
don't want to leave evidently what the
methods that they use are uh it's kind
of like old-timey it looks like an
old-timey spa like i really love the
production design on this by the way
but it looks like a really old-timey spa
or like an old-timey
mental asylum or something like that it
looks kind of like that so one of the
main things they use is hydrotherapy and
most of this is utilizing this
supposedly miraculous water
from the natural aquifer that's
underneath the castle where the spot is
and as lockhart kind of like wanders
around it does seem like the patience
that he sees who all seem to be like
having a good time they're playing
croquet and like you know doing
landscape paintings and [ __ ] like that
like adam the lawn uh they all have
little white pajamas and white robes and
slippers and they all look super comfy
um they all look pretty happy and like
pretty relaxed so dr vollmer says okay
well i i tell you what he's like you
can't go see pembroke now because
visiting hours are over but i tell you
what i'll do like he has a therapy
tonight at like seven or whatever and
you can come back later tonight and see
him then like maybe he probably won't
want to go with you but we'll ask him
you know he's not a prisoner or anything
like that
so lockhart's like well [ __ ] me now he
has like four hours to kill so he says
to the driver um take me back down to
the town so i can get a hotel or
whatever
but
on the way back down the hill like down
to the town
they're involved in a horrific car
accident where like a big deer like runs
in front of the car the car like [ __ ]
flips it's just it's a whole situation
so that happens and then lockhart wakes
up presumably three days later
and he is now ensconced in the spa like
in a hospital bed with a horribly
horribly broken leg so from then on the
mystery about the spa begins to deepen
and lockhart starts to become like more
and more convinced that something very
sinister is going on even though most of
the patients he talks to including
pembroke uh seem very serene and seem
happy there and like i said don't want
to leave the one exception although
she's kind of like she's not so much oh
i want to leave but she has like a
different thing going on
uh is this weird young woman named
hannah now she's actually played by mia
goth who i just talked about not too
long ago because she was in uh x the
thai west movie from 2022.
now she's one of the only people at the
spa who isn't old
and she's also
the only one that's not actively
receiving treatments
he asks about this and she says oh
that's because dr vollmer says i'm a
special case although she doesn't appear
to know what that means
and she also tells lockhart that she
doesn't really remember how long she's
been there she's like i've just been
here as long as i can remember
um the only thing she does know is that
dr vollmer told her that her father will
come and get her when she's well again
she has presumably never met her father
doesn't know who her father is so as the
plot unfolds very slowly although i
didn't mind that like i said it's a very
long movie it's a commitment so i didn't
even realize like when i started hearing
about the movie and i assumed because
horror movies are generally shorter
other than like the shining but that's
kind of like the exception that proves
the rule because that's kind of more i
don't want to even say that's like more
art house kind of film this one i don't
even want to say that either this one
kind of has like a little more art house
kind of thing to it but it's more like a
gothic melodrama but it's also like
really grotesque in that way that has
like really [ __ ] up like body horror
in it too as it goes on like lockhart as
well as the viewer and that's my
probably my only very very minor
complaint is that you will probably
figure out what's going well maybe not
exactly but you'll probably figure out
what's going on before lockhart does
he's not like the sharpest tool in the
shed um you know what i mean let's let's
call it that but yeah so you're sure
that whatever's going on at this spa
though has something to do
with the water because they're very
adamant about oh the water it has
healing properties and it's miraculous
and it's really good for you so it's
like they just oh just drink the water
it's so good it'll make it'll cure what
ails you [ __ ] like that so you know that
whatever's going on like has something
to do with the water also you're pretty
sure that whatever's going on has
something to do with like the creepy
history of the place which he gets told
i think by the driver and then like
another woman that's a patient there
that is kind of like a history buff and
so she knows like does a little bit of
research about it and the whole thing
was that the place
originally was owned by this baron who
ended up uh marrying his sister
and then he was trying to cure her of
what you don't really know until later
on
but of course because there was some
incest going on up there the townsfolk
weren't having that and they actually
like burned the place to the ground like
200 years ago or something like that and
then the place was like subsequently uh
rebuilt so there's kind of like still a
lot of animosity like between the towns
because they kind of like you know
generations ago they kind of like
remember that [ __ ] also uh in this movie
there are lots and lots and lots of eels
uh wriggling around in very eel-like
fashion as they do during multiple
scenes though for a time you're not
actually sure if they're really there or
if lockhart is actually losing his mind
and hallucinating them
as a side effect of the treatment
because in fact for a while i think kind
of much like shutter island the movie
kind of teases us with the possibility
that lockhart might actually have been
sent to the spot as a patient like all
along and he might be experiencing like
a nervous breakdown which because they
kind of go into like he had some [ __ ]
that happened to him in the past because
his dad was also like this high-powered
executive i think i believe in the same
company and when he was a kid like his
dad committed suicide like you know
basically pulled over in a car like at a
bridge and like jumped off a bridge
while the kid was in the car and he has
like a lot of unresolved like emotions
about that and like guilt about that for
not helping him so you're kind of like
so obviously he's really troubled so you
think maybe oh there's something going
on like maybe he's imagining all this or
maybe he's been a patient here the whole
time or something like that so they do
kind of like tease that possibility also
now this isn't a gory movie by any means
but i will say if you are very squeamish
about creepy crawlies about eels in
particular
or snakes i guess but mostly eels uh
you're gonna have a bad time because
there's a lot of eels and they are kind
of everywhere they're going to people's
mouths they're going up they're swimming
around it's it's it's not a good time so
like i said
uh there's also one very wince inducing
dental sequence so if you're very
sensitive to violence involving teeth uh
you might want to cover your eyes during
that part because it may be your ears
too because it's uh it's pretty nasty
it's pretty nasty like i was just like
watching i was like holy [ __ ] i can't
believe they [ __ ] because a lot of
times they'll kind of like show it a
little bit and then like cut away but
this one didn't really cut away just
kind of like yep there there they go
they're they're going right in there so
yeah so it was that i will say to you
and this isn't really a criticism
but i will say that the main character
of lockhart is fairly unlikable but like
i said i don't mind that because he's
supposed to be i mean he's supposed to
be kind of a douche at the beginning
like i'm this go-getting executive like
with no you know not like american
psycho territory but kind of like that
where he's just kind of like he doesn't
have a wife or kids or pets or anything
like that like he doesn't care about
anything but advancement and like making
money and [ __ ] like that and as the
story goes on you actually start to feel
more and more sympathy for him as he you
know kind of gets more and more trapped
by his circumstances and there's like a
bunch of gaslighting going on like is he
really a patient here are they just
telling him that like what the [ __ ] is
going on uh honey and he also does
evolve as a character
you know kind of slowly losing this
selfish cold arrogance you know the
shell that he has as his predicament
like gets more and more dire like as the
movie goes on and as he also realizes
that he has feelings for hannah the
young girl there and that he really
needs to you know get both of them the
[ __ ] out of there because she's in
danger
now as i mentioned this film is quite
long but
in my opinion i don't feel like it
dragged i mean i was pretty into it like
from the beginning you know the mystery
was really compelling i you know like i
said you can kind of see where it's
going but not exactly like i didn't i
didn't get like the full
you know the full like convoluted glory
of it like you know what i mean but you
pick up bits and pieces so you kind of
know like where it's going um and i
really really liked the whole vibe of
the visuals like some of them were like
really disquieting like there's
especially like this one scene sort of
near the beginning i guess where he
first gets to the um gets to the spot
and he's looking for pembroke and they
say oh he's in the steam bath or
whatever and he like goes in there and
it's just this really weird like dream
like kind of like he goes in the in the
steam rooms and there's all these rooms
and there's nobody in there and then
like he goes around and he goes in one
room and then he looks and like all the
doors are gone and like [ __ ] like that
and then like a deer walks back it's
crazy so it's so it has like a lot of
dream like like really weird grotesque
imagery like that which i really dug and
the ending i'm not gonna which i'm not
gonna spoil but it pulls out all the
stops and just goes full on
banana pants like toward the end but
like i said if you kind of approach this
as
a gothic horror that is
absolutely embracing all of the excess
that usually comes with that genre
then um i think you'll find a lot to
appreciate in this movie at least as i
did i mean like i said
just like everything everything is
subjective it's a gorgeous film to look
at the plot is a bit complicated and
maybe slightly nonsensical i didn't find
it that it actually did make sense to me
but some people i've heard other people
make that criticism but i was actually
invested all the way through and i just
rolled with whatever was going on like i
said it's a little crazy toward the end
but i kind of liked that it just kind of
went over the top uh it really is a
fascinating film
and
i think it deserves kind of more
appreciation and more consideration just
for this peculiar
work of art that it is i mean this is a
director who made like the first three
pirates of the caribbean movies he's
like a big director and the fact that
they gave him all this money and he made
this bizarro
[ __ ] horror movie like i said that
should be applauded and i kind of wish
that more directors would just do crazy
[ __ ] like that um so you know props to
gore verbinski for just going all out
and saying yeah i'm gonna i don't give a
[ __ ] if this makes money or not
apparently um i'm just gonna make what
the [ __ ] i want to make and it's this
nutty like [ __ ] gothic crazy thing uh
but yeah so the movie is currently on 2b
for free at least in the us if you would
like to watch it i'm sure it has it's on
other streaming services as well and i
actually really liked it if you like
gothic stuff if you like some of the
guillermo del toro stuff this stuff like
that it's kind of in that sort of vein
like i said like shutter island a little
bit of frankenstein kind of stuff so if
you like that kind of stuff then you
will probably dig it as well although
like i said it is a time commitment it's
two and a half hours long so just know
that going in and that will do it for
this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one bye